in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Pam is
with us hi Pam how are you yes fine Dave
are you better than I deserve welcome
and where are you from Kansas City
Missouri
cool and who's this young lady with you
my daughter Brianna Brianna how old is
Brianna is 15 hey welcome Brianna good
to have you good to have you so welcome
from Kansas City here to do your
debt-free scream yes how much have you
paid off $93,000 way to go and how long
did that take you 40 months 40 months
yes love it and making what kind of
range of income during that 40 months
between thirty four and forty thousand
excellent and what do you do for a
living a health care insurance Wow oh
you have that's amazing and forty months
to pay that much off of that income yes
you have been on beans and rice kiddo
that's what made us because we're
vegetarians I love it it's awesome way
to go what kind of that was ninety three
thousand dollars a lift the mortgage you
paid off your house yes you're so weird
no I was born weird you make thirty four
to forty thousand dollars a year and you
paid off your house
I was desperate to get it done in 40
months old are you
41 and you are paid for house yes you're
so weird I know thank you oh love it
what is this house worth a 120 that 120
way to go I'm so proud of you sis
awesome thank you bye Hannah that is
serious business have you ever been debt
free as an adult no not really I know
most people haven't know as in buying
your family had a paid-for house that
you remember no yeah most people don't
know most people live debt to death
family debt to family dead he goes on
and you broke the cycle yes Briana you
rise your mama completely broke the
cycle no she's a freaking hero I mean
this is amazing way to go so tell me
what happened forty months ago that got
you this fired up well it actually
started like in 2007 and I was this to a
financial advisor and I didn't quite
agree what I was hearing and it sounds
like okay I just
give up and listen to something else and
I saw this random come and say oh you
need to listen to Dave Ramsey and I'm
like okay completely forgot about it and
three years into my mortgage I was I had
absolutely nothing to do so all of a
sudden is voice and I was like you need
to listen to Dave Ramsey and I'm like
okay so I turn on like one video and
with that five minutes the first thing I
heard you say was why not pay off your
mortgage today I'm like I didn't think
of that
yeah and so and that was all he took for
me is somebody saying it was okay to do
it gave you for me I had never mind I've
heard in once they pay off your debt
today Wow and and here we are just a
little over three years later and boom
you're done easy just yeah you see that
wasn't easy but you did yeah yeah it's
only 40 months that part's easy you got
the rest of your life to live without
payment in the world no it's nice
and you're gonna be able to barreled
serious well yes that's actually I'm
serious I mean I don't know why you
wouldn't be a millionaire at retirement
oh yes a good plan it really should yeah
you really should be I mean you've got
cuz you owe me payments you make 40,000
you don't have a payment in the world I
mean you just pay your own house payment
and and that'll probably turn into a
million dollars in 20-something years
give or take I mean we'll see but I mean
that's pretty close good for you
yeah out of you thank you and it was
more of your videos that I was trying to
figure out how am I supposed to do this
because I never heard him once they pay
off your house I said the first thing I
heard you say was um set a time limit
when do you want to pay your house I've
looked all seven years I think I want to
say from seven years I end up getting
paid off in six years ten and a half
months so that was really a good point
for me so I was excited wow that's
amazing
very very well done I was just just
fabulous just fabulous what do you tell
people the key to getting out of that is
the key would be to use the key of
common sense and stop spending money on
fun things and spend money on debt that
need to be paid and so my my opinions as
long as you have debt you need to just
pay people back and don't just spend
money on fine things get it cleared up
get it out yeah cuz then you got your
life back yeah I mean because the
borrower is slave to the lender and now
that you owe me a payments you really
feel free different yes it's a different
thing I mean it's like way different yes
well congratulations so proud of you
guys I know Briana's proud of you she
made the trip down here with you to do
the debt free scream and everything very
cool we're going to give you a copy of
Chris Hogan's number-one best-selling
book a signed copy it's called retire
inspired because that's your next step
yes and that's not gold there we go
that's right yeah we want you to retire
wealthy and be able to live and give
like no one else as you go along through
this journey so you're gonna be able to
help some other people and you've set a
standard for Briana she's she you know
she won't be able to be normal now she
won't be able to be in debt and be broke
cuz she'd be looking at her mama going
my mama has sense yes mama had sense
mama has sense I like it
alright Pam and Briana Kansas City
Missouri $93,000 paid off making thirty
four to four thousand a year and she's
debt free don't tell me you can't do it
she did it count it down let's hear a
debt free scream three two one well done
oh that is awesome awesome you know we
have a lot of people that are on here
that you know guy while ago making one
hundred and seven thousand dollars doing
their debt free screams right but I
particularly love it when someone as
brave as Pam fights through making
$30,000 a year forty thousand dollars a
year and she paid the seniors pal for
debts pay off her house her house there
you go just like that
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show you can do this you know that
really is a message whether you've got
two hundred seventy thousand dollars in
student loan debt or twenty seven
thousand well you've got a fifty
thousand dollar income a five hundred
thousand dollar intercom
you